Our Universe is a mystery.
It's a collection of mysteries.
The more we learn,
the more we realise
that there’s a lot more
that we do not know.
Here are five big mysteries.
There is no reason to believe
that our Universe is unique.
It is quite possible that just
as our Universe was created,
many universes were also created.
If that is the case, then we live,
not in a single Universe,
but in a vast collection
of universes
that physicists refer to
as the multiverse.
We can think of those
as island universes -
each with its own quirks,
maybe even each
with its own laws of physics.
For example, there could be
one of these other universes
where gravity is 100 times stronger
than it is in our Universe.
If we could somehow
prove conclusively
the existence of multiple universes,
of the multiverse,
that would be a genuine
intellectual revolution -
a complete change
in our cosmic thinking.
The dark side of the Universe
is a really big mystery.
The dark matter
and the dark energy
make up no less than 96%
of what the Universe contains.
The stuff that you and I,
the Sun, the Earth,
the stars, the galaxies are made of,
that is just the icing on the cake.
It makes up only 4%
of what our Universe contains.
The most likely explanation
for the dark matter is that
it is made up of some exotic
fundamental particle
that came into existence
just a tiny fraction of a second
after our Universe was formed
in the Big Bang.
But it is a mystery.
We have compelling evidence
that it's there.
We suspect
it's a fundamental particle.
But, frustratingly,
it has yet to be discovered.
I think most people have heard
about black holes.
Fewer may have heard about
white holes.
White holes are in a way
the opposite of a black hole.
Black holes eat everything.
White holes kind of
vomit everything out.
Nothing can come out
of a black hole.
Nothing can go into
a white hole.
Whether white holes exist
or not
is a matter of heated debate.
Of course, if they do exist,
they are fascinating,
and they may even raise the possibility
that they act as tunnels
to other universes,
or indeed to other epochs
in our own Universe.
But they remain
hypothetical objects.
The current view in cosmology
is that everything we see
in the Universe - everything -
started life as something called
a quantum fluctuation.
Sounds mysterious.
Let me explain what this is.
When the Universe was born,
it expanded very rapidly
in a very short period of time
known as "cosmic inflation".
As the Universe expanded,
these quantum fluctuations
were stretched,
and this stretching seeded the Universe
with tiny ripples.
These ripples yet
are the origin of galaxies,
galaxy clusters, planets,
the Earth, and people.
The mystery here is,
is it really possible
that a sub-microscopic entity
like a quantum fluctuation
could eventually grow
into the Milky Way galaxies?
If you had told me that a few years
ago, I would have thought,
"You're really out of your mind."
And yet today, the standard model
of the formation of cosmic structure
is exactly what I just described.
Time fascinates, not just physicists,
it fascinates everyone.
And yet, it is a relative concept.
For example, if you travel
faster and faster and faster,
time slows down
more and more and more.
If you travel at the speed
of light, time simply stops.
If you look at the equations
of physics,
it is striking that time can go
forwards or backwards -
the equations of physics
don’t distinguish.
Because of this,
many people believe
that you can travel into the past,
because there is nothing
in the equations of physics
that forbids you doing that.
It is quite possible that we could
in principle travel back in time,
so long as we do not introduce
any inconsistency with the future.
So that’s five big cosmic mysteries.
But each mystery -
as is always the case in science -
leads to another, even bigger, mystery.
And we haven’t even got to possibly
the biggest mystery of them all -
are we alone in the Universe?
But that’s a whole new story.